the Kurdish L Syrian Democratic forces
or the SDF is in control of Eastern
dezur but it's facing an armed Uprising
by the mainly Arab population who want
to manage their own region people here
helped the SDF defeat isil also known as
Dash and before that the Syrian regime
in the province in eastern Syria but
they say their lives have not improved
they complain of harsh and
discriminatory treatment by those in
power and collapsed economy in an oil
Rich region the recent fighting made it
worse now we have almost nothing all I
have is this 1,000 Syrian L to buy bread
that's less than 10
cents a brief ceasefire fell apart when
Arab tribes felt Promises by the SDF
leadership for reform and a new
relationship were not serious but there
is concern that the Syrian regime and
its Ally Iran whose forces are on the
other side side of the eufrates river
will take advantage of the unrest with
the potential goal of driving US troops
out of Syria some Arab tribes do
collaborate with the regime the SDF is
backed by the US and says it has
repelled multiple infiltration
attempts the regime and Iran are trying
to take advantage of the situation if
they're able to create security chaos
the Americans will be forced to leave
the Arab tribes are trying to avoid this
option but so far the SDF and the US
haven't meet the demands for economic
and political rights for international
players this corner of Syria is
strategic it is here where the US
maintains a limited Military footprint
to prevent the expansion of Iran and
Russia Iranian backed militias and
pro-assad militias uh use this Corridor
for trafficking of all kinds again
weapons drugs like captagon and other
Goods for the Americans and for the
International Community this region is
important to ensure the lasting defeat
of dases and while the heavily armed SDF
has been able to hold its ground it's
ruling over a restive population and
facing an armed Rebellion zah aljazera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer